let's get some practice counting money
so I have six coins right over here and
these are all United States coins or
counting money in the United States for
these examples and what is this first
coin well this is called a quarter or a
quarter dollar so it represents twenty
five cents and we could write it out as
twenty five cents but I'll just write it
as twenty well I'll just keep that one
like that now this one is another
quarter so it is also going to be it is
also going to be twenty five cents now
this one looks different but it's just
the other side of this coin of these
coins this what the other side looks
like so this is this is also going to be
twenty five cents these are three
quarters right over here so how much how
much money do these three quarters
represent well it's going to be 25 plus
25 which is 50 plus 25 which is going to
be 75 so these three quarters are going
to be 75 75 cents and remember a hundred
cents make a dollar so this is still
less than one dollar but we're not done
yet we have this nickel this is a nickel
right over here that represents five
cents and then we have another nickel
here it looks different was just the
other side this is the head side this is
the tail side so this is also another
five cents and so these two nickels if
you add them together they are going to
represent ten ten cents and then finally
you have a penny and a penny and it even
says it right over here is one cent in
fact they all say it here this is five
cents this says one cent so this right
over here is going to be one cent so
what is 75 plus ten plus one well 75
plus ten is 85 plus one is 86 so this is
equal to 86 cents and if it was if it
felt a little bit too fast to count up
25 50 75 in your head you could also add
them up 25 25 25 plus five plus five and
another five plus one plus one you could
add them up this way
and then what would you get 5 plus 5 is
10 plus 5 is 15 plus 5 is 20 plus 5 is
25 plus 1 is 26 so that's two tens and
one six put the two tens up here 2 plus
2 is 4 4 plus 2 is 6 6 plus 2 is 8 so
you could get 86 cents either way let's
do one when it has even more coins in it
so here we go we have so what is it
what's going on here this right over
here is 1/4 that's going to be 25 cents
25 cents and then we have one that we
didn't see in the previous example we
have two dimes a dime represents 10
cents so we have two dimes or we could
have those each represent 10 cents then
we have two nickels we've already seen
those each represent five cents so five
and five and then we have four pennies 1
1 2 3 4 now we could put each penny
separately like that or we could say
look for pennies each of them represent
1 cent so that's going to be 4 cents so
let me do it that way so so this 1 2 3 4
that's going to be 4 cents and then we
could just add everything up so 5 plus 0
plus 0 plus 5 is 10 plus 5 is 15 plus 4
is 19 19 is 110 and 9 1 so I can put the
110 in the tens place 1 plus 2 is 3 plus
1 is 4 plus 1 is 5 so it's 5 tens five
tens and nine ones so 59 cents this
right over here is 59 cents and notice
we have more coins but it represents
less value than the previous example
that's because we had a lot of coins
that didn't represent a lot of values
like we had these four pennies here well
in the previous example we had three
quarters quarters represent each of
these quarters is equivalent to twenty
five pennies so we're able to represent
more money with fewer coins
in the first example